as you look at the data we're getting
out of Europe we're focused so much on
Asia here the US economy such a mixed
picture how do you see things well first
of all the biggest issue I think
overhanging markets at least of you in
New York is you know the short-term and
medium-term outlook for the US economy
and the huge debate about whether we
might have a recession or not have a
recession my own view is no we're not
going to have a recession the US economy
remains and has been for some time solid
on exciting but solid you know growing
in the vicinity of 2% people forget that
the export share of the US economy is
only approximately fifteen percent there
for global weakness has a limited effect
on us I personally think the only threat
serious threat to the US economy from
the point of view of recession risk is
are the financial markets themselves and
whether a spurt of volatility and
financial market weakness could frighten
consumers and frightened businesses and
also generate a negative wealth series
of negative wealth effects so my own
view is the outlet for the u.s. is
essentially fine Europe this data is
really in keeping with the macro view
one would have which is Europe is barely
moving up you know when the vicinity of
one percent that's what you would expect
given how relatively recent the banking
and sovereign debt crisis there was
remember it was only 2011-2012 and the
whole Rogoff thesis about how long it
takes to come out from a banking crisis
so that's what you would expect so I
don't find any of this surprising and
and Europe weakness is what what we
would be what would be expect to see if
we were historians so it feels like
we've had a pretty turbulent time going
back to August where the market went way
down they came back in the fall then the
beginning of this year went way down
seem to be coming back some what is the
significance of the fact of volatility
itself as opposed to the overall level
at which the market saw period does it
really affect the economy well the way
it can affect the economy we witnessed
rather briefly last August and about
four weeks ago which is volatility
spikes it's typically inversely
correlated to equity markets for example
the higher the volatility especially if
it's spiking up the lower the markets if
you were to have a sufficient spike and
a sufficient market weakness on the
other side you can have the effects I
talked about in terms of scaring
consumers and businesses and ultimately
a negative
effect that's see that's the way that
the VIX itself and all that it
symbolizes could spill into the economy
we're not in that mode right this minute
vixx's back down and markets are or have
been have been strong and the big
question is will we see a recurrence of
the volatility of last August and four
weeks ago my own view is yes we probably
will and you don't see an effect on us
consumer spending yet no this is a one
of the things that I think too many
people don't focus on two-thirds of u.s.
gdp is consumer spending most of the
data on the consumer is encouraging it's
not discouraging the most recent data on
retail sales on on final consumer
purchases and so forth is is solid and
you would expect that with gasoline
prices as low as they are wages
beginning to move up job creation rate
being healthy that's what you would
expect so the consumer is relatively
solid any given piece of data can be a
little out of that theme but relatively
solid and therefore the US economy
two-thirds of which is the consumer is
doing okay Roger if you're on the
Federal Reserve right now you'd have a
series of data and a series of upside
surprises then you've got this concern
internationally as well but we've been
told again and again and again that
their data dependent now their data
dependent shouldn't it be hiking in
March of you were at the Fed would you
be hoping for a hike doesn't it depend
on what data it does but PC pce upside
surprise GDP upside surprise payrolls
still pretty solid so both sides of the
mandate tick tick why don't we step way
back for a minute there are so many
ironies in today's markets and one of
them is that if if we fell down from
Mars we'd be and we knew we had a lot of
economic knowledge nevertheless we'd say
to ourselves let's see historically high
oil prices high interest rates prospects
of fed tightening have been negative for
growth and therefore negative for
markets so if we were beginning to see
those indices moving that way we'd be
bearish we're in a market now where for
the moment the higher the oil price the
higher the the open market interest rate
the greater the prospect of fed tight
is bullish why because it's been so much
fear and because the absolute levels of
oil prices and interest rates for
example are so low by historical
standards but it's a historical irony
that that that the way markets are
responding is not in keeping with what
you would expect over the long term now
the prospect for the fed tightening
we've all seen with what the futures are
showing yep that that prospect is rising
if I were on the open market committee
first of all I think the rest of the
world would be terrified but other than
that I think March might be too soon
yeah just four weeks ago we were looking
at an abyss a lot of us thought at least
so I think March would be too soon but
the prospects for more fed hikes in 2016
as compared to just the one we already
saw a rising now for understandable
reasons with the data improving